so let's continue our discussion of ways
in which Donald Trump may try to subvert
or challenge the will of the people in
November of 2020 to get himself
reelected let's talk about Michigan
Michigan has been a big target of Donald
Trump's ire Michigan has been looking at
vote-by-mail they decided they are going
to be sending absentee ballot
applications to every voter now I want
to remember let's not forget that
Michigan is not sending an absentee
ballot to everyone Michigan is sending
an application for an absentee ballot to
anybody who wants one Trump tried to
argue on Twitter last week that by
sending a ballot to everybody Michigan
is doing something wrong remember that
Michigan is sending an application to
everybody and in Michigan the lieutenant
governor garland Gilchrist the second
set to MSNBC that he believes Trump
realizes he's likely to lose Michigan in
November and so he is kind of stirring
up all of this controversy over
vote-by-mail in order to create a
pretext to challenge the results in
Michigan the Lieutenant Governor
recently said in an interview with MSNBC
quote I think that the president wants
to set us up so that there can be a
conversation about the legitimacy of an
election that he is looking to lose that
is a really unfortunate thing that's not
how we do democracy here in the United
States and we need to be ready to
respond to that forcefully so you don't
need to think too hard to realize
there's a very good chance Trump is
going to call election results into
question in 2020 in in the November 20
2011 Trump won in 2016 and he still says
it was rigged so understand for three
years Donald Trump has been attacking
the trustworthiness of an election that
he won so of course he's going to
challenge the results if he loses in
November
now whether he'll get away with it we'll
discuss in a moment in terms of Michigan
Trump won Michigan it was really close
Trump won Michigan by about eleven
thousand votes over Hillary Clinton that
was zero
point three percent in terms of a margin
of victory right now Trump is losing to
Biden in Michigan in the last four polls
Trump is down by three four seven and
eight
okay the way to prevent Trump from
credibly arguing that the Michigan
results are bogus is to defeat him in a
landslide to defeat Trump so
overwhelmingly in Michigan that there is
no credible way for him to say it was
rigged and 10,000 votes 15,000 votes
were the difference-maker they are going
to bring out every trick they can and
Michigan is very likely to be a primary
target which is why Donald Trump keeps
talking about Michigan all the time
now it's also always personal for Donald
Trump part of Donald Trump's focus on
Michigan is that he's been feuding with
Gretchen Whitmer who's been the
Democratic Michigan Governor overseeing
the coronavirus response and this is a
surefire way for Donald Trump to attack
you she has been standing her ground
against Donald Trump when it comes to
coronavirus and policy her polling is
much better than Trump's in terms of
coronavirus handling so that makes Trump
absolutely furious
now let's talk about whether this will
work I've said before if Trump loses he
will likely claim it was rigged but he
will leave it's not likely to be what we
would call a peaceful transition of
power so when you look back at the bush
handoff to Barack Obama when you look at
the Obama handoff to Donald Trump we had
what we would call a peaceful transition
of power the outgoing president inviting
the incoming president to a White House
visit even though these were hard-fought
political battles we've checked every
single box for what we call a respectful
proper peaceful transition of power I
would expect Trump to continue being the
petulant child that he's proven himself
to be refusing to welcome Joe Biden to
the White House refusing to do these
perfunctory things that outgoing
presidents do and quite frankly I don't
care I don't want to get ahead of myself
if Biden wins if Biden wins the only
thing that will matter
that Joe Biden won Trump can do whatever
he wants as long as he leaves and we can
get back to something more normal now
let me throw out one other thing I've
been thinking about if Donald Trump
loses and claims that it was rigged and
still ends up leaving it could be a good
thing for the country and what I mean by
that is Donald Trump has successfully
ignored clouded not flaunted floud 'add
checks and balances ignored separations
of power emoluments attacking the media
accusing TV hosts of murder
Justice Department deciding hey we're
not gonna prosecute someone Michael
Flynn who's already pleaded guilty it
might actually be reassuring for the
United States to see Trump argue I
really want I really want I really won
and still be forced out because it would
reassure us that at least some of our
institutions are still working seeing
that an institution still works
seeing that a check-and-balance still
functions seeing Trump try to say it was
rigged but still having to leave could
be exactly the reassurance we need that
we will start to get back to something
approximating a more normal government
it's a thought and in the end all that
matters is that he does leave that's all
that really matters in the end if you
love feeding your intellectual curiosity
but you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blink its blink
Isleta consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst blink east
has books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a
trypsin is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video